- [Voiceover] This question
says, Vera's dinner plate
is divided into three
equal-sized sections.
Vera puts all her broccoli in one section.
And then we're asked, what fraction
of Vera's plate has broccoli?
Okay.
So we have we plate with
three equal-sized sections,
and we know that Vera puts
broccoli in one section,
and we're asked to
figure out what fraction
of the plate that is.
So we can draw Vera's plate,
try to represent this with a picture.
Maybe Vera's plate is a rectangle.
We don't really know,
but a rectangle will work
as long as it has three
equal-sized sections.
So let's try to draw that.
This may not be perfect.
We can probably do that
second one a little better,
but this should represent
three equal-sized sections
on a plate.
And then we know she puts broccoli in one
of those sections, so let's
use green, draw some broccoli.
Broccoli, broccoli, broccoli.
And then, look at this
picture, and ask ourselves,
what fraction of Vera's
plate has broccoli?
Well, our fraction's
gonna have a numerator.
On top will be how many
sections have broccoli,
which is one, and then,
our denominator will be
out of the total number of equal sections,
and we know there are
three equal-sized sections.
So 1/3 or one of the three
sections has broccoli.